why is it so important that every month
this jobs report comes out obviously
there's 10 million people unemployed
and there's still 10 million people
unemployed but uh you know
prior to covid you know we had the
lowest unemployment rate three and a
half percent
since 1969 i mean it was just we were
living in an incredible
era in terms of the percentage of u.s
workers who were in the workforce
and then came the pandemic and now we're
trying to sort out
when we're going to get onto the other
side of this finally
so we're at i think six point two
percent to be exact six point two
percent
ten million people still out of work you
mentioned
getting to the other side of this yep
when do you see
the other side of this actually
happening so year two years longer
at the current rate that jobs are being
created it's still going to be about two
and a half years
the problem that we're starting to see
is
permanent joblessness we call it
economic scarring
and when people have been out of the
workforce for a long time
their skills atrophy it's like if you
don't exercise for a long time your
muscles
you're floppy you get sloppy and
employers
look at people who have been out of the
workforce for a long time they're like
no
there's it's a stigma if you will and
that's
becoming problematic because even though
we've had tremendous amounts of job
creation we're pulling in
all kinds of leisure and hospitality
workers back off the sidelines
uh face-to-face service type of jobs
that
that couldn't be done until really we we
got further into the vaccination process
which we
are and it is proceeding splendidly
nationwide
so we're pulling all these people who
were sidelined back into the workforce
but yet
41 and a half percent that's a record
high post covet 41.5
of those who are unemployed have been
unemployed for 27 weeks or more
that's going to become problematic to
get themselves those numbers slowly so
41.5 so a little less than half of the
people
41 are unemployed okay have been
unemployed for 27 weeks or more
wow and that takes a year it's a half a
year and that tends to be where
employers start
to view the resume a little bit
differently
why is this person been out of work for
so long so they might look to a new job
entrant or somebody who's switching jobs
before they look to somebody who's been
out of the workforce right or wrong
but again it's just gonna have a resume
and have a blank right
six months right this is talking to our
friends out there right side
there there is something there i was uh
reading a lot i
i i was a six month gap my linkedin
feed i've got more than 250 000
followers on linkedin wow
i get bombarded uh all the time with i
can do this work i can do
a lot of people have just hung out their
own shingle in a post-covered world and
called themselves
a consultant so it's you know ddb
incorporated
and you see this a lot but you also by
the same token know that they're not
pulling in the money that they once were
so you don't want to get into a
situation where the federal government
has to step in
and effectively subsidize incomes
indefinitely that's called socialism
and we don't want to go there we
definitely do not thank you for watching
this short clip if you want to see the
full episode check it out right here and
if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment
click right here